in every story there is a hero and a
villain in your story you're both all
the bright aspects and all the dark
aspects of yourself orchestrate the
melody of your song a song that you need
to hear first before anyone else but in
order to hear it you have to learn to
listen to listen not only to what you
want but also to what you're afraid of
your fears and your darkness aren't
detached from you do not eschew them
face them analyze them internalize them
the shadow is always there and it will
always be but the shadow can look big or
it can look small depending on the angle
from which the light caresses you what
is the size of your shadow
carl gustav jung was one of the most
important psychologists of the previous
century he's also one of my biggest
influencers since he is one of the few
that have attempted to bridge the
notions of psychology and spirituality
in an effort to discover ways to
transcend the human condition jung's
work was constantly evolving and it was
this evolution that produced
comprehensive analysis of concepts like
the ego the shadow the archetypes the
collective unconscious and the anima and
animus especially the shadow has always
been an intriguing topic among people
and with regards to it jung has stated
in ion the shadow is a moral problem
that challenges the whole ego
personality for no one can become
conscious of the shadow without
considerable moral effort to become
conscious of it involves recognizing the
dark aspects of the personality as
present and real this act is the
essential condition for any kind of
self-knowledge the use of the word
shadow wasn't chosen unintentionally
jung was always good at portraying
complex ideas in an assimilable visual
manner he used the mental imagery in
order to create anchors with concepts
already familiar to human cognition the
shadow is dark and elusive it is
impossible to catch its size can alter
depending on your position in space and
it is ubiquitous whenever light is
present ergo one can form a somewhat
basic understanding of the concept
without the need to delve into arcane
terms another crucial thing to ponder is
that the shadow itself due to the
darkness that it forms and due to the
distance that it creates from the
physical body of a person
becomes something not so many people are
eager to confront and this is one of the
major ideas associated with the jungian
shadow although we usually see the
shadow as an integral part of our
existence most of us are willfully blind
to this existence our dark side is
concealed or camouflaged in a painful
attempt to protect an image that fits
the narrative we decide to espouse
through social conditioning we come to
construct a facade that can keep the
substrate of our constructed identity
stable so that we can keep feeling safe
safety however is ill-defined in that
space we inhabit how can one feel safe
when there is so much unknown territory
out there that can at any given point in
time convulse the foundations of our
fragile constitution a person is as free
as their mind allows and if the mind
creates barriers between the reality of
the person and the reality of the rest
of the world delusion and neurosis could
take over when you see people operate in
a state of enforced ignorance that
attempts to preserve a certain status
quo then the shadow can only grow bigger
and forced ignorance entitles the shadow
to take over since the individual is
incapable of controlling it because he
or she is not even aware of its
existence we can't control what we don't
understand every aspect of one's
unconscious that cannot morph into
conscious judgment will perpetually
impede one's progress for it is creating
a fantastic world that cannot
synchronize with the frequencies of the
real world in such a landscape the real
world or at least whatever we can
understand of it becomes an egotistical
battleground that leads to collision and
madness that is not how our perceptions
should meet the world should be a forum
for dialogue and constant
experimentation where we strive to
refine the moral imperatives that could
alleviate our suffering everything
beyond that should be viewed with
skepticism if that seems unclear to some
people it is clearly because the shadow
element hasn't been dealt with
effectively regardless of the
idiosyncratic nature of one's shadow the
process of assimilation has always been
universal and it is represented by the
following sequence
evidently assimilation can occur if the
stages of encounter and merger don't
take place first there is certainly a
heroic act for the angst entailed in
this process is immense there is nothing
scarier than facing the deepest realms
of yourself but there is also nothing
more rewarding than that assimilation is
a lengthy process that demands mainly
psychotherapy but also hours of
introspection and constant re-evaluation
and recalibration of personal behaviors
and beliefs our cerebral makeup is quite
malleable but its malleability is
predicated upon our ability to showcase
discipline and tenacity we can't just
expect a divine force to rescue us from
our suffering we are our only chance for
redemption and catharsis the shadow has
a challenging nature therefore the
process of assimilation requires one to
ask oneself some challenging questions
[Music]
most of you have heard the story of dr
jekyll and mr hyde the famous idiom is
inspired by the book strange case of dr
jekyll and mr hyde written by the
scottish author robert lewis stephenson
in 1886 in it he describes the life of a
man who transforms between two personae
dr henry jekyll and mr edward hyde the
story was so powerful and it resonated
with so many people that it entered the
vernacular and whenever we encounter
characters with an unpredictably dual
nature we almost immediately recall the
story of dr jekyll and mr hyde most of
us can cite events from our lives where
our actions and our intent didn't really
align we behaved as if we were different
people that's a result of a plethora of
factors that can affect our behavior and
can result in lack of congruency in what
we think feel and do social conditioning
latent desires mental fatigue and many
more reasons can come to mind the truth
however is that our ability to fight
them is within our control there are
times in my life where i feel that i
will go crazy due to other analysis of
certain instances in my paradigm i'm not
sure how to deal with specific scenarios
and more often than not i tend to
question the reality of those scenarios
my perception might be prone to certain
biases and prejudices that cloud my
judgment so i tend to question the basis
of every claim that i make despite how
awkward this process might seem it is a
process that can yield tremendous
benefits in one's journey to assimilate
the shadow your shadow due to its dark
nature is constantly forming a cloud
over your judgment this cloud can never
disappear but it can certainly abate
through meticulous introspection and
cultivation of wisdom
i never believed in moral relativism and
i never thought that our moral problems
could not be solved by some strange
technological and philosophical osmosis
we can create a universal moral
framework that can be accepted by every
soul on this planet this might sound
ambitious but trust me it is not humans
have always found ways to co-exist and
respect each other because the notion of
co-existence is central to our survival
our revolution has created countless
iterations of our species but our
bedrock is more or less the same what
does not allow us to behave constantly
in a respectful and mutually beneficial
way is the shadow when the shadow takes
over any discussion for a universal
moral framework cannot find fruitful
ground we negotiate and debate and
exchange verbal tantrums in an attempt
to defend our point of view and our
position in the dominance hierarchy of
society some people do that in a more
ethical way and in order to defend the
goodness but most just keep perpetuating
banal attitudes and approaches and it is
this banality and triviality of
existence that needs to be dealt with in
order to identify what is morally good
actually it is the combination of this
and the ability to showcase common sense
in the face of trivial matters with
common sense the discovery of a solution
to most of our problems could be
accelerated dramatically life might be
an amalgamation of complex instances but
our cognitive apparatus is more than
capable of making sense of them all it
takes is to offer clarity to our
judgment and common sense is imperative
in that respect especially when it comes
to orienting ourselves towards what is
morally good
most of life is struggle and unless we
don't voluntarily accept this as a fact
straggler will keep manifesting itself
in every facet of our existence i like
this idea a lot because it reminds me of
how important clarity is when it comes
to the betterment of our living
conditions in order to ameliorate
something you need to understand its
mechanics maybe something isn't working
well because a part that comprises the
hole is actually malfunctioning when we
break down the hole in parts and
fastidiously examine the parts we can
discover details about systems that are
usually obscure then we can go back to
the system itself and look at how what
we discovered can improve the
performance of the system as a whole a
systems approach is usually more
effective and usually more meritocratic
thus empowering the parts to work
synergistically for a common cause
clarity manifests itself in that way
when you allow the part to discover all
its nuances and all its capabilities you
end up with a reinforced version of it
that can offer more to the whole humans
operate like that and the dawn of the
internet made that idea more vivid we
experience a collective awakening that
can perhaps lead to a collective
enlightenment information becomes widely
accessible and we can improve our error
correcting mechanisms just by asking and
gathering as many views as possible that
right there is the essence of clarity
and its only obstacle is the shadow a
person who clings to outdated and
ill-defined views will only reinforce
the shadow and stagnate in a swamp of
confusion incessant knowledge seeking is
the name of the game a game we should
all prepare to play
i want to conclude this video with a
passage from the red book probably carl
jung's most important work
be silent and listen have you recognized
your madness and do you admit it have
you noticed that all your foundations
are completely mired in madness do you
not want to recognize your madness and
welcome it in a friendly manner you
wanted to accept everything so accept
madness too let the light of your
madness shine and it will suddenly dawn
on you madness is not to be despised and
not to be feared but instead you should
give it life if you want to find paths
you should also not spare madness since
it makes up such a great part of your
nature be glad that you can recognize it
for you will thus avoid becoming its
victim madness is a special form of the
spirit and clings to all teachings and
philosophies but even more to daily life
since life itself is full of craziness
and at bottom utterly logical man
strives toward reason only so that he
can make rules for himself
life itself has no rules that is its
mystery and its unknown law what you
call knowledge is an attempt to impose
something comprehensible on life there's
not much to say after you read these
words only that there is so much madness
in life but there is also so much truth
in madness
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon editor now